خداع العدو مسموح في الحرب والمعارف في
اوكرانيا ليست استثناء تصنع هذه الشركه
التشيكيه اسلحه وهميه قابله للنفخ هذه
الدبابه من طراز ابرز وهنا لعبه على شكل
رجيمات التي زودت بها الولايات المتحده
الجيش الاوكراني تنكر الشركه التشيكيه
ارسال منتجاتها الى اوكرانيا لكنها تقر
بان ارباحها تضاعفت في الاشهر الاخيره
ما لم يكن لدي منظار على بعد 200 متر لا
استطيع ان اعرف ان كان سلاحا حقيقيا ام
مزيفا هذه التقنيه ليست حديثه في نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه نشر البريطانيون
هذه الدبابات المطاطيه لايهام النازيين ان
الانزال سيكون في باتيلي وليس في
النورماندي
واعادت الحرب الاوكرانيه هذه الاسلحه
الوهميه الى نطاق الاستخدام نرى في هذا
الفيديو بطاريه مضاده للطائرات تابعه
للجيش الاوكراني في منطقه زابوريجيا
تستهدف من قبل طائره روسيه مسيره لكن هذا
الهدف ليس الا لعبه
في هذا المثال نراه بوضوح اعلى الانابيب
المطليه باللون الابيض يبدو انها من الخشب
طائره مسيره اخرى تراقب الهدف بطريقه
عموديه وبمجر انفجار المسيره الاولى قدح
ان الانابيب كانت فارغه من الواضح ان هذا
الهدف وضع كي تخسر روسيا ذخائرها وطرفان
استخدم هذه الاستراتيجيه
كما نشر الجيش الاوكراني هذه الصور التي
تظهر دبابه روسيه وهميه وقد فرغ الهواء من
سبطانتها فلجيش الروسي تاريخ طويل مع هذه
الاسلحه القابله للنفخ كما في هذا المصنع
بالقرب من موسكو الذي صور قبل 12 عاما
الجيش الفرنسي ايضا يمتلك بعض هذه الاسلحه
الوهميه لكن الهدف منها التدريب فقط